la grande bretagne a posé sa candidature
au marché commun elle l'a fait après
s'être naguère refusé à participer à la
communauté qu'on était en train de bâtir
et ensuite après avoir créer une zone de
libre échange avec six autres états et
puis enfin après avoir je peux bien le
dire on se rappelle les négociations qui
ont été menées si longuement à ce sujet
après avoir fait quelques pressions sur
les six pour empêcher que ne commence
réellement
l'application du marché comme enfin
l'angleterre a demandé à son tour à y
entrer mais suivant ses propres
conditions
cela pose sans aucun doute à chacun des
six états et ça pose à l'angleterre des
problèmes d'une très grande dimension
l'angleterre en effet elle est insulaire
est les maritimes
elle est liée par ces échanges ses
marchés son ravitaillement aux pays les
plus divers et souvent les plus
lointains elle exerce une activité
essentiellement industrielle et
commerciale et très peu agricole est là
dans tout son travail des habitudes et
des traditions très marquée très
original
bref la nature
la structure la conjoncture qui sont
propres à l'angleterre diffère
profondément de celle des continentaux
comment faire
pour que l'angleterre telle qu'elle vit
tels quels produits tels quels échanges
soient incorporées au marché commun tel
qu'il a été conçu et tel qu'il
fonctionne par exemple les moyens par
lesquels se nourrit le peuple de grande
bretagne et qui est en fait
l'importation de denrées alimentaires
acheter à bon marché dans les deux
amériques ou dans les anciens de
mignonnes tout en donnant en accordant
des subventions considérables aux
agriculteurs anglais ce moyen là est
évidemment incompatible avec le système
que les six ont établi tout
naturellement pour eux mêmes le système
d ici ça consiste à faire un tout avec
les produits agricoles de toute la
communauté a fixé rigoureusement leurs
prix
interdire qu'on les subventionnent à
organiser leur consommation entre tous
les participants et à imposer à chacun
de ses participants de verser à la
communauté tout économique il ferait en
faisant venir du dehors des aliments au
lieu de manger ce qu'offre le marché
commun